جود مورنينج
واشكركم على حضوركم معنا في هذا اليوم
التاريخي
للاجتماع الثامن
اسمحوا لي ان اقدم وزير الدفاع
جلسات اليوم
صباح الخير
يسرني ان اراكم اليوم في هذا المؤتمر
الثامن
الشجعان في اوكرانيا في دفعهما الوطنيه
الينا ايضا عبر ال
الاتصال
هذه القياده الشجاعه لوجودها بيننا ولا
نعطيهم
تصفيقا لترحيب بهم
حانوت
حزين بسقوط الطائره العموديه
قبل ايام
لقي فيها حتى هو عدد من الاوكرانيين بما
فيهم وزير الداخليه
عن بلغ حزننا لهذه الماساه
ناتي هنا لنجتمع في هذا الوقت العظيم
والوحده
50 دوله
اتت لي تساعد اوكرانيا في الدفاع عن نفسها
امام
ال عدوان وقبلها اشهر اعتقدنا ان اوكرانيا
ستنهار
وان
العالم سيتجاهل ذلك لكن بوتين لم يعتمد
على فكره انا الشعب الاوكراني شجاع
مهاره الجيش الالكتروني ولم يعتمد عليكم
ايضا وعلى كل من هم موجودين هنا على
الشاشات وحول هذه الطاوله يجب ان نحافظ
على
الزخمنا وعلى عزيمتنا في هذه المساله هذه
مرحله همم حاسبه لاوكرانيا وفي فرح همم
مرحله صعبه من الحرب نحن الجميع
ان النفس لاكرانيا لطالما يتطلب الامر همم
ما زالت روسيا مستمره في اعتدائها وقد
زادت
اعتداءاتها وقتلت كثير من الاوكرانيين
وراينا
ميار القاسي في اختيار مدينه مبروك قبل
ايام
بقصف ادى الى تدمير مبنى
ومقتل نحو سته مدنيين بما فيهم اطفال
هجمات الروسيه تهدف كسر عزيمه الشعب
الاوكراني لكنها اخفقت فالشعب الاوكراني
كان مصدر الهامل العالم
ومع ذلك فان روسيا ينفذ منها الذخيره
وتعاني
مخاطر في معركه
وتعتمد على كل قليله من شركائها المتبقين
يدعموها في هذا الغزو حتى ايران وكوريا
الشماليه لا يعترفون بانهم يزودون روسيا
الا اننا همم بالنسبه للدم الذي نقدمه
لاوكرانيا من اجل حريتها انا بعد الولايات
المتحده
زادت مساعداتها الامنيه لاوكرانيا اشهر
الماضي الولايات المتحده اعلى رات اننا
سنقدم بطا
باتريات للدفاع الجوي وكذلك
لمدرعات بدري برادلي وغيرها من المدرعات
والمساعدات الامنيه اليوم يسرني ان اعلن
مجموعه جديده من المساعدات الامريكيه
الامنيه تساعد اوكرانيا في التقدم على
ساحات المعركه
هذه تشمل
اثنين فاصل خمسه مليار دولار وهي الاكبر
كويس كويس
26 فاصل سبعه مليار دولار منذ بدايه الحرب
ايضا نقدم قدرات دفاعات جويه لحمايه المدن
والاجواء
الاوكرانيه وهي تشمل صواريخ
السام وكذلك همم مضادات دفاعيه لمساعده
اوكرانيا في تزويدهم بالمدرعات وهمم
المركبات المواجهه
وايضا
امرابط
150 مدرعه
والولايات المتحده ستواصل تزويدها للقوات
الامن الاوكرانيه
السلاح المتقدم وهذه الجهود ايضا تواكبها
من الاتحاد الاوروبي ودول الاخرى ونحن
نواصل الدعم على عده جبهات ونضع الاولويات
في قدراتنا همم للتعاون مع القوات
الاوكرانيه نحن نفكر بان نكون مع شركائنا
وحلفاءنا لدعم اوكرانيا للدفاع عن نفسها
هولندا كانت رياديه في تقديم
المركبات المدرعه وكذلك التوفير المنازل
الامن اللاجئين للاكران والالمان ايضا
قدموا همم
الدفاعات جويه باتريوت
والمانيا تواصل
بتزويد اوكرانيا
مركبات المقاتله وكذلك كندا قدمت دفاعات
الجويه وهذا استثمار كبير في مساعده
اوكرانيا للدفاع عن الاجواءها كما اعلنت
فرنسا
هذا جزء من المساعدات الاوروبيه لاوكرانيا
هذه الاعلانات وخاصه بالنسبه للدفاعات
الجويه هي نتيجه لهذه المجموعه الاتصال
اليوم سنواصل عملنا مع بعض مع بعضنا مع
بعضنا كاصدقاء اوكرانيا
ودراسه الاحتياجات همم
المباشر الان من حيث المركبات والمدرات
وكذلك فاننا
في عقابي اجتماع
لجنه تسلح فقد ناقشنا بايلزم ايضا
اوكرانيا من سلاح وكلنا هنا مجموعه لدعم
الدفاع الاوكراني نحن في مرحله حاسمه من
روسيا تعيدوا موضوع نفسها
وتجند وتحاول ان تعيد
الهجوم لكن الفتره الان لا توافي بان
نتباطا الشعب الاوكراني يراقبنا
والكرملين يراقبنا ايضا
والتاريخ ايضا يراقبنا
لن نتخلى ولا نتنازل عن عزمنا في مساعده
اوكرانيا للدفاع عن نفسها ضد العدوان
الامبريالي الروسي
نفخر اليوم بان يكون بيننا ضيف خاص وهو
الرئيس الاوكراني قيادته
كانت مصدر الهام للشعب الاوكراني وكل
الموجودين هنا في القاعه وهو يمثل روح
اوكرانيا وكما اخبر
الكونجرس الشهر الماضي فانه فقد قالها انه
اوكرانيا ما زالت على قيد الحياه بكل نشاط
فتفضل
وتقدم بكلمتك لهذه المجموعه شكرا
شكرا جزيلا
واشكركم على
طيبه التقديم واشكركم على حسن العزاء ايضا
بمن فقداهم نحن مع في هذا التحالف همم
تساعدونا في النصر انا ممتن لكم ولهذا
الحوار ولهذه الوحدات وكلنا نرى النتائج
في ساحه المعركه في اوكرانيا اشكركم من
ساحه المعركه
وحدتنا ستصبح اقوى
ما كل جوله وكل دور لكن هل لدينا وقت طويل
كلا ال الارهاب لا يترك مجال للنقاش بل هو
يباغ تو مدينه والاخرى
المدافعين عن الحريه
اااه
لن ننتظرهم كثيرا حتى يساعدونا الحرب
الروسيه والاعتداء الروسي
غير مبرر لكنه في ظل كل ما قدمناه
اوفاكس
كلنا نستطيع
ان
نتشاور والحروب لا يمكن ان ناخدها دون
سلاح نحن بحاجه بسلاح اللي يدافع ويحمي
الشعب من الضربات الجويه
الروسيه اشكركم جميعكم على كل سلاح
قدمتموه وكل سلاح منهم ساعده شعبنا من ال
هروب من وجه الخطر الروسي
الوقت ليس في صفنا بل يسابقنا كما هي
الدفاعات الجويه
والمدرعات
والعتاب والذخيره كل هذا مهم ونحن في
النهايه سنحقق النصر سيدتي
وسادتي هذه المره الاولى التي اتقدم فيها
امامكم
وزراء
ليس وزراء جيش بل وزراء دفاع دفاع لجعل
عالمنا حر ومتمدن وحضري والحريه التي نقدر
تذكر الحريه التي
كان ينظر اليها ويتطلع اليها
اجدادكم فنحن الان لابد من تحقيق هذه
الاحلام لابنائنا كل
ثقه بانكم لن تسمحوا لمثل هذه الحرب ان
تستمر
وبنقعد اقعد
ابائكم لن
يرغبوا بمثل هذا المستقبل لكم وكذلك انتم
لن ترغبوا مثل هذا المستقبل لابنائكم هذا
الدفاع ليس لاوكرانيا فقط بل للعالم
باكمله روسيا تريد ان تدمر امم
وانت تحكم فقط من موسكو